let's have a look at the state of play
where we are at the moment it's
relatively familiar if we've been
following this
uh for the last few hours maybe a couple
of
day or so it's more or less where it was
before but the counting is gradually
increasing and we are definitely getting
closer to the finish line how many more
hours it's going to be
couldn't necessarily tell you but we are
getting closer um so here we are
you can see joe biden here 253 electoral
college votes and as you know
he needs to get up to 270. so he's
essentially one big state away
two small states uh away if you've got
nevada in arizona
that would be good news for him he's
leading in both of them but the counts
are continuing i'm going to show you an
interesting
visualization of that uh nevada aren't
counting that much in the moment but uh
arizona
are but still a long way to go and by
the way alaska will probably be
republican
but over here is probably where the
action is going to be in the next few
hours so we've got georgia
uh down there they are getting really
close to having a result there
trump in front in georgia trump in front
of north carolina as well
um but trump also in front of
pennsylvania and i want to talk about
pennsylvania because that's an area
where things
are starting to change so come across
here and i'll show you
let's bring up pennsylvania there it is
too close to call in pennsylvania
um the lead about a hundred and kind of
110
112 000 at this stage actually probably
better to think in terms of numbers of
votes rather than just these percentages
so trump about 110 000
but there's still about half a million
votes yet to count a bit more than half
a million
and the thing is they are breaking for
joe biden so votes in particular kind of
philadelphia
um to some extent pittsburgh as well
they're going towards joe biden
at the moment and that's just the
pattern that we've seen throughout this
this election you'll probably recall
that
recall have some states whether it was
iowa um in various other places
texas as well for a while looked like
they were joe bidens and then they kind
of went to donald trump we've seen this
kind of
wave where it's gone from one party to
another and this gives you a good kind
of illustration of
what we're talking about here so this
shows you from the start of the counting
because this is counted gradually which
uh party which
um candidate pennsylvania was going for
so look at the start
joe biden blew for democrats joe biden
was leading and then
as those on the day votes came in donald
trump
took the lead in pennsylvania a crucial
state here
20 electoral college votes if joe biden
got it he would win the presidency
uh if donald trump got it it would make
that path a little bit more difficult
and what you can see is this look these
two lines narrowing
and narrowing over the course of the
following
hours and that's where we are at the
moment about
two percentage points in it between
these two men
as i say about a hundred thousand a
hundred and fifteen maybe thousand votes
but the key is the votes that have been
canceled now are coming from more
metropolitan areas that tend to favor
joe biden so if that continues
pennsylvania looks good for him
how about arizona he's in the lead in
arizona at the moment that's the
democrat line
but again you see the same thing as
we've got closer towards the end 75
80 of votes counted look donald trump's
votes this is a traditionally
republican state donald trump's votes
have gone up
joe bidens have gone down and the
question mark is whether
we see a crossover there that's going to
be interesting to watch
as is i mentioned georgia a moment ago
let's have a look at georgia
because this is you could hardly get a
more traditional republican state this
is who they voted for over the
last four elections uh it's gone
republican all
the time it would be incredibly unusual
actually if joe biden were to win
in georgia he'd be the first
non-southern democrat to win in this
state since i think 1960 since kind of
before civil rights
john f kennedy kind of period and it's
worth just considering
where they are now it is so tight it's
razor
tight if you look at the numbers here
just look at that you've got maybe about
13 000 votes in it or so in georgia
and they are 98 in
and you've seen the same thing as george
in georgia as i showed you a moment ago
uh in pennsylvania with joe biden
catching up gradually
and he's catching up because counties
like fulton said this is basically
atlanta you know this is your big
metropolitan area there you can see
atlanta there in the heart of georgia
and the votes have been coming in thick
and fast for joe biden 72
73 of the vote going to joe biden in
this county so we're looking at county
level data within
georgia is that going to be enough for
him it's going to be so tight it's gonna
be so tight i mean like the math says he
could technically do it but it's gonna
be pretty
ambitious if he does and finally it's
worth your thinking about
what that does to the electoral college
map
if um he does it well let's consider
this okay so if
you give georgia to joe biden
probably spotted this already come and
have a look he's up to 269 now that
means two things first of all
it means donald trump cannot
automatically win the presidency it
would be a tie if he got it but
uh second and it means if joe biden got
any of these states nevada arizona
probably not going to get alaska but
north carolina pennsylvania
then he is in the white house so georgia
could be
massive for him but controversially as
well if
donald trump wins the rest of these
states well what happens let's fill them
all in red
269 each that would be a tie will be the
first time
since 1800 i think you probably know
that your history better on this stuff
but the first time since 1800
thomas jefferson aaron burr would go on
for days
weeks perhaps house of representatives
state delegations would have to work out
who was going to be president but
in a sense let's hope that's not going
to happen it's going to be a long
unwinding road anyway
let's just remind ourselves though where
we are so forget about 269 have a look
at this instead our virtual
white house and you can see where the
race is right now that's
joe biden 253 electoral college votes
ahead of donald trump with 214 but
still we're not there yet we're getting
closer
but we're not at the finishing line yet